it's official tomorrow june 19th will
also be known as juneteenth and it's now
a federal holiday
president biden signed that into law
yesterday and called it one of his
greatest honors
today in which you remember the
moral stain the terrible toll
that slavery took on the country and
continues to take
what i've long called america's original
sin
during yesterday's ceremony president
biden thanked 94 year old civil rights
activist opal lee
she's known as the grandmother of
juneteenth five years ago
lee walked from texas to washington d.c
to urge
congress to act and she's grateful to
finally see change
i'm joyful
i'm humble
i'm going to do a holy dance this is one
of the ways
to acknowledge our ancestors
weren't free for two and a half years
after the emancipation proclamation
a very vibrant 94 year old loved that
juneteenth commemorates the day when
slaves were freed by
in the us back in eighteen sixty five
it's the first
new federal holiday since martin luther
king junior day
in 1983 was declared since juneteenth
falls on a saturday this year most
federal workers do have today
off however the post office says it will
not be closed today
because of the short turnaround alex
there are several national celebrations
of juneteenth coming up this weekend
amc theaters is presenting the amc black
picture showcase
it starts today at town square here in
town they're airing films like fences
do the right thing and the water man
they will play for a week those tickets
start at five dollars
also here in the valley the discovery
children's museum holding a juneteenth
celebration
on saturday it's tomorrow 10 a.m to 5
p.m the museum
will have a poetry reading by vogue
robinson the poet laureate for clark
county
there will also be several special
workshops too the first 250 kids to show
up get in for free